but now let's move on to the rest of the
day's news Libya State oil firm says
that it's been forced to halt operations
at five major oil ports in the east of
the country
its facilities have been under attack by
forces who are loyal to the warlord
Khalifa Haftar who say that the port's
revenues are being used by the rival
Tripoli based government to pay Turkish
fighters the National Oil Corporation
says that 800 thousand barrels a day of
output will be lost that amounts to some
55 million dollars a day
well the UN's envoy for Libya says that
oil revenues should be used to feed
people not to Leaney I don't really
clear our position at the UN is very
clear we must not play with oil because
it is the livelihood of Libyans without
oil Libyans are starving we have to tell
it like it is so we must not play with
oil we must not turn it into a weapon of
war we must not allow it to become a
matter of division or outbidding al
jazeera's mahmoud of the warhead is in
tripoli and says the oil blockade has
already had substantial effects on the
market in less than 24 hours the libyan
dinar has lost about 10% of its value
compared to hard currencies because of
the blockade of the oil terminals and
oil exporting ports in the east of the
country the united nations support
mission in libya has expressed concern
over the blockade of the oil
installations and it said that the oil
sector must not be part of the conflict
and the NOC that's the state oil firm
the National Oil Corporation must stay
neutral away from the current or the
conflict that's going on the oil
revenues are the backbone of Libya's
national income and the National Oil
Corporation is stressing that it's now
losing about eight hundred thousand
billion barrels a day and which is
estimated at about 55 million dollars a
day loss because of the blockade